uh dominique i i actually want to jump
backwards for a second uh episode 10 of
last season the was
what was it like reading that script for
the first time and seeing what you were
going to be asked to do because it's not
like
making a tv show is very limited
schedule very limited time and you're
being put through the [ __ ] ringer in
that episode so i'm just curious what it
was like filming that and you know i
mean by that point i turned to naren and
i was like are you guys trying to kill
me because
honestly like i was so exhausted by my
ten
i mean i'd already been emotionally
strung out from the bloody pella
in slapped around by my son and my baby
dad you know i've jumped into space it
was
i was exhausted i i was really at the
end of my um kind of rope in many ways
but i i think it lent to the energy of
that episode and where she was at
and um
i mean that scene
that kind of plays out in my helmet
i just when breck was like we're gonna
shoot it all profile in your helmet i
was like
this is not gonna work
and um
it was so
delightful watching it back because i
think it's one of the most powerful
sequences we've had in the show
and it works so well and it's so
heartbreaking and
um it felt like a gift at the end of
this this very difficult
season very rewarding a very difficult
season for naomi and what i had to do as
an actress so
yeah it was
weird as acton is and fabulous and
i feel kind of honoured to be able to
tell her story in this way it's great
jumping into season six um i've seen the
entire season uh i think fans are gonna
have uh what we call they're gonna be
very happy
what what do you guys wanna tease people
or what can you say about season six
because i know i can't say anything
[Laughter]
cop out yeah
i mean i think it delivers a climax to
every single character arc and every
major theme
in in a very dramatic way um
you know we came into this year really
wanting to close out this story strong
and um
you know i i really feel we accomplished
that i'm very
really proud of this year and it was
there was an incredible satisfaction
being able to
to make it and
and put it together and i think and i
hope that
fans find the same i think i think we
you know we've always had the most
superb writing
um i think we really end on a on a
really elegant note with this show um
yeah i think what i'm really happy about
they're gonna be deeply satisfied with
the the wrapping up of this um
this saga this journey that we've all
been on for six years so
yeah
what uh i heard that it was like on
sundays you guys got together or used to
get together and read the scripts
together
so i'm wondering what it was like when
they finally delivered the season series
finale into the inbox or handed you the
script what was it like reading that
that finale script did you do it
together um and emotionally what was it
like it was quite weird actually because
we shot episodes one and six of the
season together
and because breck came and that was his
block so we actually done the end of the
beginning together so we read the final
script um
right at the beginning so that was
actually quite weird because we've never
had that before in a season where we've
done the end first
um
[Music]
but it was a lot
again it's such a satisfying end that i
just think it was really nice to do the
whole season knowing that we suck the
land in because nobody wants you know
fans to watch this and be like well they
[ __ ] it they [ __ ] the ending um i
don't think there's anything worse and
we've all had that disappointment not
too long ago
so i'm like you know
for me it was just i think i just it
actually was quite relieving
to be like oh
thank you for writing an excellent final
app and and something that i think one
we can all be proud of but that the fans
are just going to be
happy with and this as a body of work is
complete in this gorgeous way
so that was mine
i agree it was an enormous relief you
know when we
when we finished
that
that end
you know it's obviously bittersweet in
all in all the ways i mean you know
the
the people on the expanse or the reason
why
it is what it is i mean you know we
still
pretty much have the entire crew from
season one on our show you know i mean
it really speaks to the culture that
we've that we've had here for seven
years
the people who come to work love it we
love going and making this thing
and um
and it's and it's this beautiful
creation that we've made and i think
you know the irony of it is that when we
when we did complete it there was there
was that enormous relief because the
anxiety of not being able to deliver on
that
for whatever reason was gone
we knew we had it and um
it it was like oh god we made it okay we
made it i can deal with the emotional
ramifications of that
afterwards
but um
but we made it and we finished and
completed the story like it was my worst
nightmare to not be able to to finish
this and um
and we did so uh
yeah bittersweet um
but but proud
definitely yeah
for the people watching uh your show did
not pull a game of thrones final season
oh thank you you know i'm just gonna say
it like that which uh i really
i really enjoy i really enjoyed that
series but man that final season
missed the mark um and uh you know but
one of the things is it what has it been
like as actors because your emotional
journey for both of you from where this
series started to where it ends up with
you guys being together it's been just
awesome to watch but it's also it must
be rewarding as actors to portray
characters like this you know changing
so much so can you both talk about that
yeah i mean again i just think the
expanse is
expert
depicting humanity and
um
human relations in like their most
truest honest kind of flawed
non-linear
glories and i feel that way about holden
naomi i'm just like
you know this strikes me as a real fully
fleshed out
uh journey of a relationship that a lot
of people have the constant choosing to
be together
is
the crux of a relationship um
and you know if you've ever been in one
in real life you'll know that it's it's
always a choice and they always chose
each other no matter how difficult that
was no matter what that cost them there
was always that choice of like you're my
person
so i just think um
you know as with gnarly especially right
at the beginning i mean they were
completely at odds with each other but
to get to this final moment
in season six and it'd be so beautiful
and so and mature and um this
common ground this very mutual respect
this kind of uh
understanding of each other's politics
and beliefs and respect of that and how
that's influenced their decisions in
that moment
i found it deeply satisfying and it was
probably the only way i would have
wanted the show to end actually for them
and so yeah it was excellent
likewise i mean it's
it's exceedingly rare that you are able
to
to create a relationship
and build it justifiably step by step
for six years i mean um
[Music]
you know it it allowed us to really
portray
the growth in a very realistic way i
mean you know these two have really
clung to each other amidst this crazy
storm going on around them
and
um and through it all they
they've they've kept each other
grounded and kept each other alive and
um
through respect and love and
um
you know the way that it that it
culminates in the end i think is
is a really appropriate
uh beautiful way to kind of have a
the send-off that these characters
really deserve um
yeah it was amazing i mean
amazing
uh which of your friends and family are
the most excited that you're on this
series and which of them is always the
one asking you for spoilers
they're so funny because like none of my
family watched the show up until
recently my mum started watching it
and now she is that guy
she's actually like don't tell me don't
tell me i can't wait for season six and
it's really cute but for a long time i
only had one friend my mate aussie who
had even watched it
so uh
he's also an actor so he wouldn't have
asked for spoilers but um oh and my
partner chopper is a huge fan of the
show so he's also very cute
we both don't spoil each other's shows
um
so yeah but no one else has seen it
apart from those three
that's okay though for me i'm quite
happy with that
i have uh
one of my my oldest friends uh is uh is
a screenwriter on a bunch of television
shows and
he is a
big fan of this show and always has been
and um
struggles with me not telling him
like what's what's gonna happen he's
like [ __ ] don't just don't tell me like
we'll we'll be talking all the way
through
while i'm shooting just catching up and
um
he's like so what episode are you on
like
i'm like four he's like
do you wanna tell me what's going on i'm
like do you wanna know he's like
god
no
no
[ __ ] no okay
um it's really fun though i uh
yeah yeah a bunch of a lot of friends
watch it and um
my family all loves it too so it's it's
been great uh i'm curious if you this
you go in you know this is gonna be the
final season um how much throughout the
season were you carefully borrowing
things from set that they might not
notice and then in the last week just
grabbing everything with two hands
i like i can't work out if this question
is like
a kind of view people have of actors or
like what you guys would do if you were
on the set because i'm like i do not
steal stuff from my set like they need
those things to show
wes takes everything
he tells me
i mean i i take what i'm given which is
like my chair back
um i don't steal stuff from this set
it's not stealing it's borrowing
bring it back
i was gifted the coffee cup which was
very nice he said gifted i think
i heard that yeah gifted i was gifted
the coffee cup um
but yeah i no
didn't steal anything but
if it would have been anything it
probably would have been the coffee cup
it was given to me anyway it's really
hard to steal stuff from the expense
even if we wanted to because it's like
what do i take a
chair like a spacer or
the whole rafting yes thank you
the whole rossignol just pull it out of
the stage a screen like i don't know
what do i take the our table oh god no
not that anything with that
table well so you can't smash it to
pieces
what over the course of the of the six
seasons though what and i don't know if
you'll remember it off the top of your
head off the top of your head but what
what sequence or scene ended up being
the effing backbreaker the one that you
were like this needs to stop shooting
that's an excellent question
i mean there's been quite a few
actually
um
i've got to say my least favorite scenes
to shoot
are like the battle scenes because
we're often not facing each other or
looking at each other so they're just
shouting at each other in this set
they're acting down
and then like you kind of like shake and
do all these things and it's just like i
always feel like such a wanker
um and i don't enjoy them like i'm going
to shout and pant for four hours until
we get this scene they're my least
favorite scenes to shoot so i'm also
like oh a battle scene okay
just gotta get through this for today
but they always look excellent right
when they're cut with all the vfx and it
cuts to everyone else on the ship and
but at the time it's like you're just
shouting at a screen
and kind of like looking to left and
right to whoever is kind of in your
periphery that you can't see
so i'm going to go with those
those million scenes that we've shot
wire work in the suits
wire work in the suit
the battle scene yeah wire work in the
suits wire work on on its own
is
is not as fun and but with the
with the suits oh my god they're heavy
and they and they're and they're and
they're weighted in odd places and it's
like
by your private property it's just like
it's
all kinds of abuse it's brutal um yeah
that's
the one that i've ever enjoyed no those
are tough and we all like lose our
temper by the
they're all just like sweating and like
drenched dropped like so many pounds by
the end of the day in those spacesuits
because they're neoprene and they're
gross just gross
sacrifice
yeah
yeah
well i was gonna say i have to stop
there they're gonna throw me out i
really want to say a sincere thank you
for making the series i really have
loved it and um thank you for your work
and thank you for talking today thank
you so much man good to see you
you